il faut vite dire ce qu'on a à dire
avant qu'une coupe il se passe des
choses vraiment très malsaine nous ne
pouvons pas nous soumettre à la loi du
silence
maintenant un flash spécial impôts on
apprend que la chaîne nationale ubp
billets a brutalement interrompu la
diffusion de son propre chef au cancer
qui coule c'est sur moi qui vont braquer
les projecteurs attention rêve qui se
réalise stone
[Musique]
on va faire plus simple c'est alex qu'on
va appeler elle a quitté le plateau en
direct le
c'est fini pour moi je ne reviendrai pas
qu'ils ont pris des décisions sans m'en
parler ils m'ont fait du mal
on va trouver une solution ne me dis pas
qu'on va trouver une solution il y a un
prix à payer pour le succès et la gloire
vous êtes adamo retourne le compliment
il y aura toujours une part de moi qui
cherche actrice mais je n'ai jamais
voulu être cette personne
on n'avait pas prévu une homélie
[Musique]
tout a changé en une minute le monde
entier a changé je croyais a coûté un
binôme franchement baddeley être ami
avec toi c'est le parcours du combattant
tu as parlé à bitche c'est lui qui t'a
dit ça les gens méritent de connaître la
vérité personne
on a écrit beaucoup de choses sur le
morning show et sur le fait que la
course à l'audimat justifie à et
autorisait les pires comportements vous
pensez que ces problèmes qu'on peut
qualifier de majeurs sont réglés et
saufs
[Musique]